when like it started nearly 10 years ago
the first project that we took on to
develop into a film was Coraline the
second project that we started
developing was a book called here be
monsters by Alan so which ultimately
became the film the boxtrolls and when I
read it one of the things I loved about
it was that it was really reminiscent of
the kinds of things that I loved growing
up the kinds of stories that I love
reading things by Charles Dickens a
roald dahl it had a great really biting
sense of humor like you find in monty
python and all these wonderful creatures
and characters and environments but it
was also 550 pages long and so trying to
you know if you do a straight adaptation
that it's a 12 hour movie and even
though you know the the animators are up
for a challenge that's maybe a little
too much so it took us nearly nearly
eight years to kind of distill all that
down to the essence of what you just saw
and in the end it was it was all of us
kind of focusing on what kind of
resonated with us personally and and
ultimately became a story about families
about about parents and their children
the intimate connections between parents
and our children and then once you get
to that core then you can start layering
in some of the ideas and the metaphor
and the weirdness and everything else
which ultimately we did when we first
read the book your first impression is
it's too big you know it's a big giant
action adventure comedy to do in a
stop-motion film so that you know we
knew that it would have to be a hybrid
so probably in every shot in the movie
except for a handful there's some CG
element I mean there's always the CG of
in the rapid prototype faces you usually
have a seam in the middle of the face
that separates where the top of the
eyebrow element is in the bottom of the
mouth them so that's always digitally
we've removed that scene that's true in
all the films but even beyond that in
the atmosphere in the CG extensions you
know in the sequence where fish eggs
insurer escaping across the rooftops the
puppets are real they're on wires every
single thing they touch is really built
or be nine foot tall buildings with
rooftops but the view to the horizon the
moonscape in the fog and all that is CG
set extensions they're the biggest
puppet in the film is far away the
largest we've ever had it like it which
was the mecca drill that snatcher rides
at the at the end of the film it ended
up being over five feet tall eighty
pounds that's the biggest puppet egg
puppet there
ever been every animator that worked on
it was a little nervous working on it is
all the rig's had to make sure it was
going to stay in place I mean it was it
had its own sense of precarious and it's
just working with it one thing that I
read is that because of all of the
different permutations and and the face
all the different expressions are able
to do the character of eggs has 1.4
million possible facial expressions can
you guys explain to me how without
making our heads hurt and explode how
that's even possible the you know like
as I said it's for as a lot of
expressions you have the upper part of
his face which is the brows in different
positions and every position you need to
animate from one to another and then the
lower part of its face which are there's
different emotional expressions but
there's also different mouth shapes so
he had 15,000 different actual objects
that were made that were printed out and
then you can put them together in
different ways over a million different
potential expressions which to explain
it more simply there's an old school way
of doing a animation in with puppets and
it's called replacement animation where
you you sculpt a facial expression and
then once you'd go on to the next mouth
shape or expression you take the face
off and you put a new one on the old way
of doing it was was carving it out of
clay or sculpting it or you're doing
something with wood the way we've
brought it into the new era is by using
rapid prototyping was it which is a
technique where we model something in a
computer and then send those files to a
3d printer and it prints out what's in
the computer as a physical object you
can hold that hold in your hand it's
crazy like Star Trek technology it's not
something that should exist it's really
unsettling on some level these virtual
things that then you exist and so that's
a way that we can get a lot more
subtlety and nuance and expressivity in
these characters faces by using
technology and combining that with craft
one of my favorite things about the film
is that kind of kota at the end where we
see Travis in there as the animator and
that's you and Richard I awadhe ya doing
that how much of that was the two of you
just riffing and how much of that was
written out I think it was probably 5050
a lot of it was written out and then we
just kind of improvised around it but
it's kind of know I've never I've done a
couple of kind of animated features now
and that's the first time I've ever been
in a booth with someone
which was kind of nice because it meant
that you you could just kind of bounce
off each other you know and it was it's
nicer than just being an adult booth on
your own just saying you know your lines
in right sir ben we were all together a
few months ago at comic-con and we had
we did a panel and one of the things
that I thought was really fascinating
was you told the whole crowd that you
recorded most if not all of your lines
of snatcher laying down because I'm lazy
what what did you seriously find that
was able to help you with well I was
thrilled when i saw the puppet and and i
think the physical shape to a certain
extent dictates the voice that comes out
of it and he's very narcissistic grand
egos and it needed to have a completely
relaxed and confident voice so it was
rather like when there's reclining a
plane see they rigged it up so quickly i
got into the studio did are not tony and
said it stood up not working sitting not
working lying down it just came out of
the right place so I mean it was they
rigged it up very quickly and it did he
he has to talk from that hollow hungry
bottomless pit of a belly that he has
that ambition it's the ambitious clawing
voice that that that I tried to find in
reclining it just came out that way too
it was wonderful that the way it came
out that way I think that's the
wonderful thing about working with these
chaps is that they allow you to have
layers to your performance and whenever
I asked to play a villain I try and find
the wound that he's trying to cover and
love that wound and then see how he or
she in my case I'm course played both
sexes in this world how they how they
cover that how they cover that would one
of my favorite sequences is near the
beginning where we kind of really look
get a glimpse into the boxtrolls world
after they come up to the street and
they get the clock and a little teddy
bear that plays the music and and as
they're going all going to bed and I
love that sequence it was I just found
it so hypnotic and one of the things is
so fascinating about is that there's
hardly any dialogue just occasional
grunt here and there what was the
thought process by
and that was that a specific decision
you guys made to have a three or four
minute or whatever it is sequence with
no dialogue in it well you needed to get
to know that what this community was
like that they loved eggs that he loved
them and it had it had to be in
pantomime and it had to be visceral I
mean so you know a child a toddler you
know being taken care of by this entire
community you know that stuff isn't in
the books the fact that they sleep in a
big cube and stuff that's all stuff we
added in the story department added as
we tried to figure out what the
requirements for that growing up
sequence work because you needed to know
really quickly they love this kid and
then he needs to you know become 11
years old and we need to move on with
the story so it's what are those primal
images of putting a baby to bed and have
the whole village gathering to go to
sleep all on top of each other in a big
sleeping pile you know all that stuff
comes out in the storyboarding process
and we wanted to start juxtaposition
between what they're set up as which is
these horrible hideous child murdering
monsters and they and when you look at
them by all appearances it seems like
okay I could buy that they're not
adorable little balls of fluff they look
pretty creepy but then when you actually
see them they don't earn our admiration
or an hour and our love because they're
beautiful to look at is because they're
sweet gentle souls who care about this
this kid and it's a very loving
community that's committed to each other
and and that's why you know this is this
is a community that we want to get
behind support of the course of making
the film it's not because they're
beautiful it's because they're there
they're just incredibly sweet creatures
I think also if you'd had a lot of
dialogue in those scenes you would have
pushed the audience away whereas that
lack of dialogue makes you it's very
intriguing the audience sort of lean
into them whereas if he if they explain
themselves away there's nothing for us
to to engage with so I thought that lack
of dialogue was a wonderful way of
pulling people in its magical I love it
and Nick for a fan for people like me
who are fans of your movies with Simon
Pegg I was really excited when I learned
that the two of you were both doing
voices in this film but this is the rare
case where you're not together all the
time did it feel like you didn't have
your you know favorite little blanket
with you that you didn't actually get to
work with Simon
no no dude yeah i mean he's my best man
we've been friends for 22 years and it's
always nice to I didn't even know that
Simon was in the film until about three
months ago he you know we just kind of
didn't talk about it to one another and
then we were having dinner one night and
he said I'm doing this thing called
boxtrolls Owen oh I'm doing that to her
and that was it isn't that was yeah we
were we were in